qué tal buenos días bueno lo primero por
supuesto fue el shock haber maradona
venía con problemas de salud había
tenido esa operación de hematoma
subdural el 3 de noviembre y se pensaba
de todos modos que había logrado cierto
nivel de estabilidad sin embargo por eso
cuando se conoció la noticia de su
fallecimiento el 25 de noviembre el
miércoles lo primero fue el shock al
poco tiempo comenzó la salida de la
gente a la calle a diferentes puntos de
la ciudad de buenos aires- para
despedirse de su ídolo y sobre todo por
cómo se vio el movimiento en la calle
para celebrar su vida y luego la
organización de este velatorio que
primero fue solo para la familia durante
las horas de la madrugada del jueves y
luego se volvió a un velatorio o abierto
al público que debió formar una larga
fila saliendo de la casa rosada- de la
casa de gobierno que llegó a medir dos
kilómetros o incluso más para poder
ingresar brevemente pararse frente al
féretro de maradona y hacer su despedida
muchos le arrojaban camisetas y otras
ofrendas a su ídolo mientras pasaban por
ahí el problema es que se concentró
mucha gente mucha gente quiso entrar y
se había puesto un límite
para el ingreso en un momento parecía
ser que no iban a poder ingresar todos
iba a ser un poco obvio y empezó a ver
diferentes tipos de desmanes e
incidentes con la policía incluso
empezaron algunos a saltar las vallas de
la casa rosada- un ingreso masivo de
algunas personas a la casa rosada que se
volvió algo fuera de control finalmente
se pudo controlar pero se implicó que el
féretro se moviera del lugar dentro
mismo de la casa rosada- y después de
varias ideas de modificaciones de el
cronograma que pasaron por ejemplo con
la idea de extender hasta las 7 de la
tarde algo que se iba a aportar a las
cuatro de la tarde bueno finalmente se
cerraron en forma definitiva las puertas
de la casa rosada no se permitió más el
ingreso de gente terminó diría incluso
un poquito antes el velatorio bueno fue
una conclusión tal vez no esperada pero
se desbordó la situación
natalio que sigue ahora tras la muerte
de este astro del fútbol
hay varias preguntas abiertas ya sabemos
que el campeonato de fútbol argentino
pasó a llamarse diego armando maradona
queremos también empezar a ver qué tipo
de homenajes habrá hacia la figura de
maradona con el correr del tiempo qué
lugares recibirán su nombre por ejemplo
esas son cosas que están por verse y
algo clave cuál será el lugar de
peregrinación de los fanáticos de
maradona de la gente por ejemplo de la
iglesia maradoniana esa peculiar
religión argentina porque el cementerio
donde fue enterrado es un cementerio
privado que no es de acceso público así
que también estaremos atento a ver a
dónde empieza seguramente en forma
espontánea a concurrir la gente y por
otro lado qué pasará con la herencia de
diego armando maradona incluso es
difícil por lo que se sabe calcular la
fortuna y cuáles son los bienes y las
propiedades de maradona y como maradona
tiene al menos cinco hijos reconocidos
dos de su primer matrimonio sus hijas
las más visibles las más conocidas bueno
qué pasará con esa herencia bueno creo
que veremos muchos capítulos sobre él
sobre esta disputa que seguramente
existirá veremos sí o no sobre él
y que había realmente entre los bienes
de diego armando maradona un tema que es
por supuesto se va a seguir
desarrollando en argentina y en el mundo
natalio muchísimas gracias entonces que
tenga usted un feliz día